[Applause]
excellent thank you i'll order five
covers table two five pigeon salad
five brill today's starter is a very
rustic pigeon salad with a hazelnut
vinaigrette and it has to be the most
perfect time of the year for pigeon
salad
this is a fantastic mix of flavors with
a gamy taste of pigeon
set off by the rich nuttiness of
hazelnuts the earthiness of the beetroot
combined with the oak leaf lettuce
wake you're waking now now it's uh yes
understand what you're doing don't panic
don't rush yes
but get a grip now you've probably never
cooked with pigeon before but it really
is easy very straightforward so
go on have a go now we're not cooking
town pigeons from chibago square these
actually wood pigeons that have led a
much happier life
and obviously eaten from all over the
woodlands making them a lot tastier bird
[Music]
now the secret behind cooking the pigeon
perfectly is you've only got to cook it
between four and five minutes
start off on the skin color it and turn
it over and then put your butter in
helping us cook tonight our two comments
this week is danny he's a 21 year old
from essex
he's passionate about cooking and he's
been working in kitchens for six years
he's a chef at pub brasserie in essex
i just really want to better my career i
want to be successful in what i do i
don't
i don't want to work in a pub for the
rest of my life i want to work in
london's top restaurant
and phil he's 19 and he's from the world
and has just won world chef of the year
2005.
is that a good thing i'll find out
tonight i want to be right up there at
the top with a
lot with the likes of gordon ramsey's to
work in claridge's be massive i want
phil in there doing that now
i want phil in there doing that now i
want
phil in there doing that now that's
three times i'm not saying it again
yeah there you go control it i want the
oil nice and brown not black phil
and don't be scared to take it off the
heat when it's getting too hot yes
pigeon is a very lean meat you know that
very very little fat in the center so be
very careful because
if it's too hot you're gonna overcook it
yeah it dries out instantly be very
careful
phil and danny are competing head to
head and at the end of the night i'll
decide who's staying and who's going
home
now to finish the top of the salad we've
got cloves of garlic they've been sliced
very very thin
but that's too strong for this salad so
we're gonna fry it very quickly
once they're cooked drain them from the
oil
and you've got these really nice fine
garlic chips
okay start the plate up yes that's your
bowl
dandelion sugar bowl start off with a
nice little handful of nuts quick
gently gently okay beetroot on top
some picked coriander leaves in there
coriander
some beans in there now don't get your
hands in there yet don't you dare get
your hands in there yet this is salad
that dresses itself
rock salt just a touch in there yes
okay now watch you get the bowl you just
roll it round i don't want hands in
there
combine the salad the beans nuts
coriander
on let's go make sure it's evenly
distributed
yes good watch you get the breast like
that
and you just slice down almost like
you're slicing smoked salmon
then you get your vinaigrette it just
glaze over whilst it's still nice and
warm
yeah okay now garlic chips
you take your little handful you just
scatter them around nicely you don't
throw them on there you just scatter
them around
the smell coming from that plate is
phenomenal you happy with that yeah
good send it first out of the pigeon
table six please beetroot lots more
hazelnuts yeah
don't skim
okay then how was the pigeon uh lovely a
beautiful fat really happy bird nice
wood pigeon yeah
not a naughty trafalgar square thing
really happy with it salad
a little bit imbalanced i thought a
little bit yeah the beetroot i wouldn't
walk a mile for but really
that's great and what about the uh what
about the turkeys what about the
christmas dinner
is that coming along it started off as a
really good idea but it looked lovely
but i didn't actually realize how much
hard work was involved in sort of coming
to terms with growing your own christmas
dinner the turkeys are at war and poor
old gary is coming off worse i don't
know who pets on him go on
like jello oh she pecks on everybody she
pecks on my bum
i want to be sure the turkeys are really
fattening up peter the vet has suggested
that we weigh them each week
peter what i brought along with me today
is a spring balance spring balance and a
bag that we can put him in almost like a
fishnet that's right yeah
okay and this is a good way to remind
the kids that the turkeys are livestock
for the christmas
table and not pets two handles on the
side
there we go here we go anthony no he's
on five
let's get stevia 11 kilos ainsley is
running uh
six kilos
oh dear nigella doesn't seem keen to
reveal her weight
such a [ __ ] come on what's that
twelve and a half kilo 12
she is definitely the biggest bird mate
so dealer nigella are big birds
jamie gary and ainsley need to put on
some muscle
[Music]
and little anthony is the runt of the
bunch
next morning we're out early to feed up
those turkeys
oh come on oh now hold come on darling
let's go say good morning to the turkeys
yes
yeah let's go up
[Music]
it seems that the perch couldn't take
nigella's weight oh no
nigella i can't believe she's broken the
stand
nothing like that nothing nothing
nothing nigella nigel scrapes anthony's
feet mr troublemaker nigella is the big
troublemaker
i'm worried about nigella's aggressive
behavior so i've brought in some expert
help
we're all getting very concerned about
nigella she's over 12.5 kilo
is it normal for a bird to be so big the
the fleshy parts develop much more
the cruncles down here these are all the
bobby bits this is the wattle
and he's just got a little beard here
see that's just growing
it's like horse hair i can't believe
nigella's got a beard
i think she's a man really yeah she's
not a nigella she's a nigel
and nigella's not the only she that's a
he
the other turkeys her uncles and wattles
are a dead giveaway apparently
so nigel is a man ainslie and anthony
are girls
that means delia the big one i mean
that clearly looks like a man i think it
should be dennis actually
it looks like gary is a man gary is a
man
yeah which is good news i think it's
good news for harry now
jamie at the back is an interesting one
you sometimes get turkeys that
look as though they could be either or
sometimes does happen
god i'm sure whenever their sex they'll
taste delicious
how are you yeah that was the pigeon was
fantastic
i'd never had pigeon before and it was
really tender and really
really nice and the whole the whole all
the flavors mixed together the beetroot
and the garlic and everything it was it
was lovely
i imagined that it would taste like
chicken
but in fact it's a very meaty taste it's
it's very nice a bit
like beef in fact i didn't actually
realize you're such a foodie
i love it i really love love food
absolutely now
um you're a bit of a ladies man yeah
as a romance no but i mean okay would
you prefer taking them out for dinner or
would you prefer cooking a romantic
night
i think cooking a romantic meal is the
best thing i cooked some wild salmon
recently
wild salmon and it's just very simple
just um
with some olive oil lemon probably let
it down by doing mashed potatoes
which is real voice food isn't
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i'll see you later thank you good to see
you thank you
[Music]
next on the menu along with our main
course of brilliant red wine
that's disgusting though what's all this
stuff we discover what's really in the
humble supermarket sausage
skin rained crystal tendon sinew
and rod stewart's fiancee drops in just
weeks away from giving birth
[Applause]
ready phil ready's ready yes have we
tabled happy
yeah four brule and four bro let's go
yes welcome back to the f word remember
everything i cook here you can quite
easily cook at home
have a go wakey wakey please
now time for the main course which is
brill poaching red wine served with
crushed celeriac
finished with a touch of cream and
roasted salsafy
table's going now mark people don't
actually think about cooking
a white fish in a red wine but it
actually tastes amazing and
it looks fantastic when you cut into it
braille raise a sharp knife fill it
nice long slices that's the first one
off
[Applause]
up
brill bones and turbot bones are the
most sought after in any kitchen
that will make the most perfect fish
stop skin
and just pull
[Music]
this little bit here is called the skirt
that's lovely
inside of fish pie it really is
delicious
season both sides
red wine thyme
bay leaf garlic salt
pepper and olive oil
poach
[Music]
[Applause]
the sauce shallots
um it's a bit of a sort of cooked thing
really because onions are far too strong
a shallot it's quite mellow
butter and get some real nice color on
there
i want this nice real nut brown flavor
on the shallots
[Music]
[Applause]
sugar really starts to caramelize those
shallots
beautiful shine on there raspberry
vinegar in
and it just sort of wakes everything up
a little bit
add poaching wine
reduce
50 grams of butter shake it into the
sauce
fish slice onto the plate
[Music]
grill the red wine sauce done
now when you're filling a fish use a
very flexible sharp knife because
let the knife do the work and a brew
like this actually comes
with his own instructions because all we
have to do is follow the lines
so we start from the head and come in
cut round the head and then just
one clean sweep down that line and just
go all the way down to the tail
and look what happens the knife actually
cuts away
the fillet and then lay the fill it back
on top of the grill
and just follow the knife all the way
through
that's the first fillet off literally
two sweeps
every drawer should have these four very
simple straightforward knives
the fillet knife that does the work for
you that's a flexible blade that bends
round the bone on the fish
and doesn't allow it
oh me
okay oh [ __ ] i've just stabbed benny um
have you got a plaster
neil oh your knife okay
to go with the grill we're serving two
vegetables you may not have cooked with
before
crushed lariat brought together with
some cream and then some roasted salsa
pie
salsified tastes like a cross between
artichoke and turnip
don't overcook it as it adds great
texture to the dish
i add it to onions sauteed in oil a knob
of butter grounds them nicely
and finishes off the flavour
now celeriac is a very versatile
vegetable great at the puree
even great in soups and you can actually
eat it raw
okay place ready place ready in the
restaurant tonight
is rachel cook a journalist who's
passionate about good food
hello rachel hello good to see you
how was your picture uh it was delicious
yes thank you it was a wood pigeon
and so you must um care about meat i
mean where your meat comes from i've
always cared
sort of not just for my own personal
benefit but obviously for the customer
benefit the fact that we give them that
level of security to make sure
that transparency is there for them to
understand so you've been looking into
supermarket meats for us
i have i've been looking at sausages
i've been trying to look beyond the
packaging to see what actually goes into
the sausage
in the uk we spend over half a billion
pounds on sausages every year
but do you really know how much meat
goes into your average economy banger
and do you know what else goes in there
besides does it taste meaty it does
taste good
it looks a bit bendy i'd say it's about
17.
70 meat that is actually an economy
sausage from a supermarket and it
contains 32
meat i'm appalled that a sausage can
have as little as 32
meat the rest of it is mainly water and
breadcrumbs by the way
but more shocking still is what that 32
can be made up of
when it says meat on a label for a
product such as a sausage
it doesn't actually just mean lean meat
it means other things like
fat connective tissue and connective
tissue
is things like skin rind gristle
tendon sinew so over half the so-called
meat content can be gristle and fat
and it's still allowed to be called meat
on the label
it is safe and it is legal but if i'm
going to eat gristle and sinew i want to
know about it
and i think the current labeling system
is misleading
earlier this year gordon and his team of
food technologists investigated the
contents of economy sausages
from the big four supermarkets to see
how much so-called connective tissue
they contained in total
the results are enlightening if not
surprising
our research showed that the connective
tissue levels varied amongst the
supermarkets
morrisons had 7.5 percent asda 10
sainsbury's 22 and tesco 24
connective tissue so according to tests
carried out by gordon
earlier this year the economy sausage
being sold by britain's biggest
supermarket
contains the most connective tissue that
skin
rind gristle tendon and sinew to you and
me
so how can you spot better quality
sausages in the supermarket
well there's one very simple trick to
remember when buying
if a packet of sausages is labeled
simply
sausages like these the legal
requirement is that they contain just 32
meat if on the other hand the label says
pork sausages like these the legal
requirement is that they contain
42 meat
to demonstrate what all this means in
practical terms i went to visit top
butcher's moan and sons
winner of 12 awards at this year's
national sausage competition
show me what you put in one of your
sausages this is the meat here this is
for
an 80 meat content sausage and how many
um
sausages would you be able to make out
of that meat approximately 120.
so richard you're going to help me make
a sausage that's just on the limit of
the regulations
now i'm going to make 120 sausages this
is the meat from my sausages
that doesn't look like meat at all how
much is that
what percentage this is a 32 meat
content sausage
looks disgusting though what's all this
stuff um well this is
connective tissue you're allowed a
quarter in in your recipe
right and this is pork fat and you're
allowed 30
we've also got this is that going in the
sausage too yeah that's
the extra bits you know so long as you
declare it on your label
then that's fine so going into the
barely legal banger is 32
meat which includes fat and gristle
then extra fat and gristle three kilos
of rust
and some coloring and herbs
so here it is the barely legal banger
technically
it's a sausage and under current
labeling guidelines it can be sold as a
sausage
i think the law should be looked into
just to clarify
what is actually called meat
in my mind meat is really lean meat
and fat i wouldn't really call bristles
and and skin or connective tissues
um mint so how did our testers react
when they found out exactly what we put
in our barely legal banger
it's repulsive i mean you can basically
just get away with anything but just by
putting the meat down
you would assume that if it says meat
you would hope it's
the finest cuts of the best raised beef
or pork
now i think i will go for it really oh
my gosh
so when you're shopping for meat always
read the label check the water content
check the percentage of meat included
but remember that with sausages
55 of the meat can be made up of fat and
gristle and that's in addition to the
fat and gristle that you'll find on the
label
secondly if you're buying sausages
always look out for the ones that are
labeled pork sausages
rather than the ones that are just
vaguely labeled sausages they're more
likely to have more meat in them
so if you're not keen on connective
tissue you might want to think about
which supermarket you buy your sausages
from
that looked extremely grim yeah quite
grim what are your sort of main
conclusions then after that
i think there are two things first thing
is that the label may not tell you
all there is to know so read it
carefully and
if you want less connective tissue in
your economy sausage
then well i wouldn't go to tesco or
sainsbury's
now we'll put a little bit of satisfy on
top of these last ones yes so lift up
the brill
drain it no no nice and gently lift it
up
okay and the curvy side sits up
okay so it doesn't look upside down
that's it good
lift it up drain off the red wine
and sauce generous on the sauce okay
because all the sauce is is the cooking
liquor from the grill
okay so that's why
okay table mark please good
very nice table late gently excuse me
go table eight good
[Applause]
the main course was was lovely i really
liked all the different flavors that
were going on
well i thought i actually thought the
fish was really succulent and the sauce
it really complemented it well it was
quite spicy and quite tangy it's really
good
um not so sure was underneath it it was
fine um i don't know what it was but
yeah i think it really all went
together quite well
okay how was that it was fantastic i
love it it's all kind of dark purple
then you cut in and it's white
bright brilliant white and you have that
smell of red wine and onion so you think
you're eating steak and then it tastes
like fish and it reminds you
how meaty the grill is and it's it's
slimming yeah now for some bizarre
reason last week we actually
started talking about your sperm count
and my spelling it's amazing we must
have run out other things to talk about
it was because it was because i
discovered that sperm counts have
dropped off over the last 50 years you
know
among males all over the world and and
partly because of diet
and i thought i might find out what my
sperm count was and see if i could do
anything to improve it
with what i eat i found out eight years
ago that i have a low sperm count and
last week
giles went to have his checked out too
[Music]
well i don't really know what i was
worrying about there it's uh
the old magic is still there his camp
was fine
but the sperm was slightly misshapen
yours
is 14 which is borderline in the last 50
years toxins in the food chain have
helped cause the average man's sperm
count to plummet more than 50 percent
misshapen or immobile sperm is
increasingly common
diet can play a major part in increase
in men's fertility
and top sperm foods include nuts red
peppers cabbage
fish and dairy and zeta yeah is there a
crisis with men's sperm
there is male fertility is definitely on
the decline and i think that men are
really neglected
in this whole area and you really
believe that a diet can actually help
increase the sort of
the sperm you know development
production yeah absolutely
what kind of things should they eat well
the food we've got here nuts and seeds
are very very important
rich in selenium rich in zinc oily fish
very important rich in
omega-3 dha very important the head and
the tails of the spa
and then fruit and vegetables rich in
antioxidants vitamin c vitamin
e to protect the sperm against damage
from free radicals
uh is there something i can specifically
eat to to improve the shape of
my sperm yeah i think that that you know
the food here
would be very very good um alongside uh
drinking plenty of water
um and lifestyle factors and in your
case charles you know a lot of alcohol
if i haven't drunk lots of alcohol how
am i going to end up in a position to
meet people and then
you're not clearly not listening to what
zeta said stop drinking
gordon first of all can i just say i'm
really pleased you're here
what exactly is the problem yeah well i
was told just coming up for two years
ago
that i had poor spare motility i
produced sperm but they don't go
anywhere and in that situation
there'd be no chance of a just having a
baby
but is there any form of diet zeta that
can actually turn gordon's problem
around and
get them moving and working well i was
talking to gordon over dinner about his
diet and you know we've
discovered that we wasn't eating
breakfast but also drinking a lot of
fizzy drinks
which contain lots of preservatives and
chemicals which you know aren't good
eating loads of crisps yeah and drinking
plenty of water i mean
you know a lot of men don't drink enough
water and sperm need to swim at the end
of the day you're not drinking the water
yeah absolutely yeah cheryl i've got a
theory about this particular sort of
low sperm count because i actually
believe
especially in the chef world a lot has
to do with the heat
and being enclosed in those confined
conditions under that amount of pressure
and when you look at the position of a
stove in a kitchen it really is online
with your
scrotum i've got my chefs to go and do a
test
and the sort of results have been quite
fascinating
um sarge two seconds
um to the sperm count how were they um
good sperm count but just you know not
not particularly um you know well in
motion and um
um deformed heads so like small narrow
heads
really yeah and cheryl is that to do
with the heat or is that a
you know a common well these studies
have shown
that that it can affect sperm what we
call sperm morphology the shape of the
sperm
right it can affect shape it can affect
the motility
and it can affect the count as well
but obviously we would have to do a
study
a proper controlled study on chefs and
actually
measure scrotal temperatures and these
sorts of things to see whether in fact
sure you are going to see it so there
could be a possibility i mean on the
back of the
you know history with the firemen the
bakers i mean you know chefs may suffer
from that problem down the line and
firstly now i'm gonna do a ring around
and maybe come back to this topic
next on the menu the pressure's on for
my commies as they go head to head over
pudding
will it be danny's pear crepes or phil's
chocolate fondant
how dare you come to the f-word with all
those french
fighting right now and you want to bring
in a chocolate fondant
and charles corrin sinks the new depths
squirrel free supper
there's the little front legs one of the
livers and kidneys the heart and soul of
the squirrel
mashed up high tasting quite smelly in a
little pie case
now it's dessert time and this week
we're going to turn up the heat on our
commies with danny and phil
cooking the dessert of their choice phil
how are we going
so what are we doing uh doing a
chocolate fondant mate yep
um between now and midnight i want you
to forget the word mate
and just remember the word gordon
because i'm not your mate where did the
idea come from uh
raymond blanc who raymond blanc i can't
hear you
i'm sure you can go have anyone heard of
rainbow blonde before
it's based on that part it's based on
red block how dare you come to the f
word
with all those french fighting right now
and you want to bring in a chocolate
fondant
huh dear oh dear so you got the egg
yolks lightly whisked and what's in the
egg white you take to like a stiff peak
or
yeah also a soft peak can you see it on
top of your head
i can't yeah we're all over there that's
the breakfast right there
right well done and if they don't come
and they stick to the mold you can blame
the french
is that right that's right gordon
fantastic that's a brave move there you
know
so phil's choice is the chocolate
fondant which is a very very brave
choice because they're so difficult to
get right
and you never know when they're perfect
and just until you're about to serve
them so when we cook them in the
restaurant we always cook
two just in case one's about to collapse
or
somewhat dry in the middle can never
happen in a restaurant now danny's
playing it really safe he's just making
a very straightforward
plain jane pancake but i have to say i
admire his balls to keep it so simple
what's inside the pancake inside the
pancake he's gonna be vanilla poached
pear
on top of the pancake he's gonna be just
like a dark chocolate
sauce so what do you put in there what
have i put in there yeah
sugar one cup two vanilla pods french
can i um can i suggest you turn it down
a little bit so the poached pears
poached not rapidly boarding yeah
still can't believe you come in here
with a french man's recipe
taro let's hope that works especially
for you especially for me
you know i love the french
[Music]
hello good to see you well you're
looking
absolutely fantastic thank you you've
been getting bigger i know
why'd you go through the motion has he
been cooking for you surely rod can cook
i mean he's
the man of the world um he does do a
good egg
and you have a sweet tooth i mean do you
like sort of chocolate fondant that is
my biggest
downfall is chocolate does he ever take
putting to bed
not put into bed no i think he doesn't
like you know crumbs and things it's
been yet to be messy
but um just the last few weeks i've been
um
having more milk he said a couple weeks
ago to me personally it's actually going
to be in the birthing floor it might be
bathing i feel bad before it gets in the
birthing pool
what's that going to be like it's like a
large jacuzzi and it's quite
yeah um and i believe that the water
will be up to about here
you're both going to be naked right he's
going to be well no i think i think he's
going to wear
trunks speedos yeah good
now it's been a bit of a manic week um
this end because um
you've been a debate about sperm and
how's rod sperm
well as you can see he's still got
plenty of bullets in this rifle as he
puts this all those
years of tight trousers and bloody
leather trousers with no pants so how
does it become so magical when we
visited the doctor last september when
we were planning to have children
he did say because of our both of our
ages it could take some time we were
like okay well
is there any particular things we can do
to help these parents
so it was he was very good he had
showers only no bath
no bubble bath um and the loose pants we
had to go out and search for these you
know
boxers and things you know no we did we
did actually freeze this though
in case there were going to be problems
oh okay later on yeah of course
we were at home we didn't do it in
enough ice cubes at home and then i
rushed down in the ferrari
with my handbag with the little violet
next to it you know i felt like i was
frozen sperm have you any idea how
expensive that ice cube could be
i know good to see you lovely thank you
thank you good to see you thank you
it's the moment of truth for the two
comments and their puddings
they're both very different desserts and
they're going to be judged by
yeah the women's institute of fulham
jean-baptiste
uh go with the pancake please i'll take
the chocolate fondant let's go
okay ladies that
is the chocolate fondant
very soft and just sort of falls away
which is good but it's not dry and
crumbly so i think that that gives them
a
thumbs up i like the paint it's not that
sweet it's very very nice
it's actually not very heavy it's nicely
like i'm fascinated
on the whole sort of women's institute
becoming a younger
vibrant sexier sort of group what the
going on
well i'm i think there's a resurgence
just like knitting's becoming cool
the wi is coming cool because we're much
more younger and i think we're coming
back to what
you know being practical is is sexy
again
but you don't look like a lady from wi
for goodness sake
well that's good that we're flying the
flag there's all changes
yeah second dessert uh a very simple um
poached pear
and in a warm pancake the presentation
looks
really good the pears
they're not crunchy and that's nice and
yet they're not sloppy
but they're just the right texture and
the chocolate's nicely as well
keep going oh this is this is really
nice and the pancake it's too much
really lovely so like a vod um chocolate
fondant or crepe
i think the crepe which surprises me
because normally i'm a chocolate freak
and i would absolutely love it but
actually
the pears were superb and i really
enjoyed the crepe
crepe definitely the crepe definitely
the crate
the crepe and i don't even like pears
it's gonna be five out of five
crap it's zero dear definitely it's the
crap
not jelly rodelia oh
yes or fish meat meat i'll get fish fish
and finally just before i go me or jamie
well that was a lovely bunch of wi
members from fulham amazing ladies um
very constructive
very critical um the winning dessert
yeah
the dessert that the diners that are
eating tonight is
the pancake yeah well done thank you
you haven't won the overall thing
however you're definitely gonna be
serving your dessert tonight
and known you yeah you're gonna take it
on the chin like a man
and really help this man with a dessert
that's not without a doubt
right uh ladies i need some help in the
kitchen yeah you're all experts right
yeah okay let's go no not washing up a
little bit more exciting than that you
know that
yeah i want some real wi pancakes
go table go you got two more to come i
need two more pancakes
followed by four more ladies yes did you
toss perfectly perfectly do it again for
me show me
yeah you can fantastic now i need five
more portions ladies
table eight so how does that feel having
the whole dining room eating your
dessert yeah feels good you're
uncomfortable at all
now it's quite amazing what's just
happened you've just served 60 customers
with your dessert and it shows how the
simple tactics
excuse me
i hear that people are still talking
about your get women back in the kitchen
campaign
this seems to have hit a real nerve and
you know what some are really happy and
some people are really unhappy but the
most important thing they're actually
talking about it
i'd rather have a career than cook to be
honest i think it's nice for a woman to
be able to cook a really nice meal for a
man to come hunt at the end of the day
i think gordon should start off for
saying that his shared responsibility
busy lifestyles everybody's
responsibility to do the cooking in a
household
women are men it doesn't matter it is
really people should be cooking i think
cooking is very good
it's very therapeutic how many women
know how to gut a chicken
my grandma could do it and i'd sit and
watch her well why should you have to
cook when you could buy it already
cooked for you
how many women know how to make the
money go further by making homemade
cakes wrestles whatever that is a lost
ass
oh i think he's absolutely right i mean
my wife
i mean she wouldn't know what to do with
a meal i mean everything's just frozen
from the freezer into the
into the microwave i'm still receiving
lots of requests of women all over the
country and
this time i went to cheshire to help two
bridget joneses
i'm georgina and this is my friend naomi
who's also my flatmate
i feel the fact that i can't cook is
really a social embarrassment
now we've got a lovely clean cooker and
oven lovely and clean because it doesn't
get used
well there isn't much cooking done in
our kitchen
but we do we are very well stocked with
cocktail glasses cocktail shakers
the blender for daiquiris cocktail
cupboard
i want gordon ramsay to teach me how to
make a meal to impress a man
we're gonna get two men rounds we're
gonna cook them some food
and we're going to make sure that they
are impressed with our food why can't
you cook
the reason i'm so bad at cooking is
because i had such a bad experience at
school
i had a cookery teacher who was mean and
she picked on me
every time i made something it was wrong
and she's put me off for life
you're both single yes yeah what
would you look for in a man i like a
nice
tall blonde hunky viking
type right okay
rough and ready and wrinkled this is the
cocktail cupboard
bloody how how many cocktail shakers
have you got three
what is that i'll give you another like
something you stick on the end of your
boobs you stick that on the end of a
glass
the place is more set out like a
cocktail bar as opposed to a kitchen
yeah
so um all jokes apart very serious yeah
um
it's not good for me to do this because
you're gonna be cooking it okay but if i
was coming around here tonight for a
date
and i'd expect a good old-fashioned
steak and chips i want you to make the
sauce for the steak okay
butter egg yolks and tarragon you with
the chips
pan of water on bring up to the boil
potatoes
parm cooked taken out the water cut into
quarters
on a tray rosemary little garlic olive
oil and they go in the oven as the guys
arrive
okay should we get cracking i know how
to do it i know you're supposed to do
that
the key to a perfect bonnet sauce is to
beat it well and you just trickle the
butter in there like that
and again don't stop
trying to get in get your fingers in
there good there you go
good what's the most important thing
about cooking a steak
getting water on it color right salt
pepper
okay and you always season the steak two
minutes before it goes in the pan
in no i told you not to throw it in
there if you're splashing it right
now we're getting colour on it right
right we come to turn it
over and in half of that butter in
please
half that's it now the butter doesn't
burn now if we put the butter in first
it will burn so the steak gets black
touch it good touch
right concentrate really concentrate
that's rare there's no bounce back
there's no bounce look
back into the pan i'm gonna take it to
medium
just put your fingers on top there and
touch that and notice
there's some spring it's coming back at
you now it's bouncing back up
it's no longer rare in the center right
so that is medium that's a beautiful
medium now we're going to take it to
medium well
well done and this is how my young cooks
start learning how to cook steak
perfectly they close their eyes and they
guess
how that steak's cooked close your eyes
drain off the potatoes yeah have we got
some olive oil yes
yeah cut the potatoes in half in half
again
and then we'll do each quarter in half
again
so we've got the meal sorted out now we
just need some men to eat it
cooking uh with two ladies tonight
actually teach them how to cook yep
okay problem is they got no fellas
fancy dinner tonight with two beautiful
girls i've got a
you've got a girlfriend what about you
same time girlfriend i'm afraid my
girlfriend cut me balls off like so
sorry mate okay because it's liverpool
chelsea are there any single men in
winslow
wow wow wow chrysler mighty that's not
bad you scrub it very well five minutes
brian you're ready bought flowers
indeed yeah they come through
[Music]
okay yeah right now i think
good lovely color
[Music]
that looks nice let's stick the salad on
the side hmm
that looks nice steak and chips rocket
parmesan salad
fresh lemon juice in there nice burn a
sauce on the side
go for it voila
bon appetit that is absolutely spot-on
we'll see if it makes the taste great
hang on ten out of ten
okay so far so good it's great well done
and just a personal message less
cocktails more cooking
good guys have a nice evening and um
i'll let myself out
yes bye bye
right um naomi and georgina good to see
you
please tell me you've done some cooking
since i've gone we have we've done the
duplicate meal actually haven't we
yeah how are the chips done oh they were
better weren't they
they were better fantastic
but nice company have a good night good
night no romance but
tonight dating no but willing
open to office open to office
there is a singleton here this evening
he's a russian critic i don't know if
you like sort of
critics oh we met him yeah what do you
think
[Laughter]
get in that kitchen stay in there yes
and stay away from the daiquiris
[Laughter]
right flipping heck um it's been a it's
been big news
in my kitchen and uh how's your sperm
count
my sperm count okay as far as i know and
i actually had them
i had a bit of trouble down there
already yeah i had um an operation
um i had a little kind of cyst that i um
on your body on my bollock i had a cyst
and um as it happened it was benign but
i'm quite happy to talk about it
i'm really sorry it's really weird
because over the last sort of five or
six years it's been brought to my
attention
yeah by my gp that i had a very low
sperm count
because of because being in the kitchen
and the heat in the kitchen when you
look at the sort of high level of a
stove nowadays
maybe the same thing for me but by doing
game shows by resting against that
lectin
perched on there family sperm cheese
it's all clear down there now it's all
good yeah
it's all absolutely good i'm so glad the
sister's gone
the sis
the sister i thought hello sister
let's keep up the cookies cheers mate
next on the menu jarl spreads the word
about an up-and-coming delicacy come on
people squirrel lovely squirrel
fresh girl it's squirrel oh no no
you wouldn't kill your cats would you if
it was tasty i might
and we find out who's staying and who's
going home the person
i'd like to stay in the f-word kitchen
[Applause]
welcome back to the f-word the food show
that's good enough to eat
so rumor has it you've actually found a
good possible source of cheap meat
it's better than cheap meat i found free
meat it's all around us i've been eating
squirrels
squirrel for goodness sake they're not
edible they're delicious
yes yes he looks all lovely and fluffy
and sweet but he's not he's a monster
in my local park he strips the bark from
the trees in the countryside he eats the
eggs of songbirds
in my garden he digs holes to hide his
stupid acorns for the winter and worst
of all he is terrorized our native red
squirrel little squirrel napkin into
near extinction i hate
grey squirrels with grey's outnumbering
reds by 66 to 1
conservationists last week announced
plans to eradicate all grey squirrels in
the vicinity of 16 newly designated red
squirrel reserves and later this month
the government plans to publish a policy
paper on grey squirrels which may well
include a new form
of squirrel contraception that's one way
of looking at the grey squirrel problem
but i've got a better solution
we could eat them it may sound a bit
disgusting if you've never had squirrel
before but i have
and it's delicious or at the very least
it is reasonably edible
and as there's only two and a half
million of them in britain it wouldn't
take that many of us to roast one up for
sunday lunch this weekend
to completely eradicate the grey
squirrel by the middle of next week and
create a lovely environment for our
little friends squirrel nutkin to make a
peaceful return to britain
i want to prove just how tasty squirrels
are when expertly cooked so i'm off to
the butler's wharf chop house in london
one of the few restaurants that has
actually featured squirrel on its menu
how'd you cook a squirrel uh squirrel's
quite small so
we're gonna have to make sure we use a
whole animal so i'll put one down now
for you
i can see you're taking off the legs
here here we have the thigh of the
squirrel which is from all that
jumping around in the trees and you know
springing around it gets that's probably
got the most meat on it
yeah we're gonna have to raise the legs
because like you said they've been
jumping around in trees so these legs
have done a lot of work
so here we've got the saddle with the
two lines in the phillips ready to be
wrapped in bacon and roasted off lovely
tasty tasty just like eating normal food
marvellous we've got the two hand legs
which we're going to braise off serve as
they are nice and seems like having
like a confit duck leg in there yeah
exactly you know rubbish high street
and we've got the the front legs the
bellies the kidneys and the livers which
are all going to be made into our nice
and that
actually is the challenging part that's
all the little bits that's the little
front legs all this little livers and
kidneys
the heart and soul of the squirrel
mashed up high tasting quite smelly
in a little pie case it's the kind of
thing i like not for the faint-hearted
squirrel meat is very lean it's low in
fat and high in protein
so craig's wrapping it in bacon to stop
it drying out
[Music]
right well just while i'm waiting for my
squirrel the sommeliers recommended a
coat doron
nice and fruity quite spicy sarah
grenache blend very drinkable and will
go nicely he reckons
uh with something as gamey as an english
squirrel
charles how's your squirrel hope you
enjoy yeah but dabbadoo
look at that little thighs for jumping
from branch to branch
mmm tasty oh it was wonderful
that is the taste of squirrel really
taste of english woodland
oak trees and very easy to eat delicious
well i've got some more cooked squirrel
and now all i need to do is convince
everybody else to eat it
fresh girl
looks like chicken of course
but tastes a bit like cross between pork
and chicken it's not a heavy taste it's
very light
i wouldn't have thought a squirrel would
have even looked like that once it was
cooked let alone taste like that do you
think you'll be having it again
um it was all right it wasn't wasn't too
bad
a bit bit you know nutty maybe
damn it's like chicken it's a little bit
gamier
quite a little bit greasy but in a good
way and um
that's not pubic hair is it no no no no
that's squirrel head squirrels don't
have pubic hair
oh no no you wouldn't kill your cat
would you
if it was tasty i might i don't know you
think it'll catch on
could do probably not
it tastes really good it tastes kind of
similar to
what just don't say taste similar to
chicken come on no it was kind of quail
or i thought when i
ate it yeah yeah is it can you imagine
can you imagine buying squirrel and
cooking it yourself
i can i think it's good so there you go
people are really pretty happy to eat
squirrel and so they should be
it's a tasty and nutritious way to get
rid of the evil gray and make an
environment fit a squirrel napkin
to return and trial so the next time
you're in your local park and you see
one of the little critters running
around
don't think oh little fairy friend think
lunch
so will you beat them again yeah they
tasted all right and if i can get rid of
them from my garden then i reckon two
birds with one stone two squirrels with
one stone definitely so is it legal
it is legal uh if they're causing damage
if you have permission from the
landowner or you are the landowner it is
permissible to shoot them and kill them
um you have to like all animals in
britain they're
protected from cruelty like any wildlife
so you have to do it cleanly you can't
go around maiming squirrels for fun
but yeah absolutely